brand new signs at the Manhattan DA's
case against Donald Trump could be
running into trouble the grand jury
abruptly canceled for today and now
sources say there is Major dissension
within the District Attorney's Office
D.A Alvin Bragg is apparently having
trouble trying to convince the jury on
potential charges due to the weakness of
the case sources also say there is a
real chance that Bragg does not even
bring charges but that's not stopping
Democrats and the media from salivating
at the prospect of arresting the former
president
the walls are closing in
the as has been said before uh you know
who is still at large
we all Rose to the occasion the papers
everybody just went there so many people
were excited you should prosecute the
case you should always give them in a
timely manner but the timely manner was
a year ago the whole world was watching
our criminal justice system and it is
the first time if he's going to be
indicted that we've indicted a former
president so I think we should take our
best shot
and Democrats are ripping Republicans
for suggesting that this could be an
overly political prosecution
it's very clear they're doing the
bidding of Donald Trump and trying to
undermine this investigation even to the
point of potentially obstructing it they
are acting like Donald Trump's criminal
defense lawyers except they also have
the subpoena power which makes them
dangerous and to hear Kevin McCarthy
also I have to say it was really more
than I could stomach talk about equal
justice
as you pointed out what he's really
interested in is the most unequal
Justice in which the Republican party
leader Donald Trump gets a pass for any
kind of criminal activity and just
listen here to Trey Gowdy who weighed in
this would be one of those rare
instances where even people on the left
ought to be able to say this is the
wrong fact pattern this is the wrong
jurisdiction and is being brought by the
wrong person on his very first day in
office Alvin Bragg announced all the
crimes that he was not going to pursue
resisting arrest so imagine how
interesting and ironic and backwards it
is that Donald Trump could resist arrest
if he's indicted interfere with the law
enforcement officer and that would not
be prosecuted
okay Greg does the media learned nothing
you know what's that Montage this
reminds me of of the North like the
nor'easters that never come you know you
go you board up the windows you buy a
case of Poland Spring and then it
doesn't show up I mean here's a
possibility did Trump just prank these
morons because this really looked like
Christmas for morons you know he's the
guy who kicked this off right the Press
fell in line they lapped it up they they
had one Collective orgasm they said they
even you could even tell Joe Scarborough
uh the the morning Beavis he even could
tell how stupid he sounded and I I like
this case because it did separate like
the idiots from the intellects it's not
down party lines at all it's like on the
right and the left the people with
working brains unclouded by ego or
ratings sought for what it is and
they're going come on this is like a
it's it's the case is flimsier than a
five dollar umbrella you do this you're
gonna break new ground you got crime out
of control in New York there's something
else going on here so all the the smart
people knew what was going on but the
other people like Scarborough and sunny
host and Adam Schiff you can't really
blame them because they are
by science's definition idiots but I
think you have to question Bragg's
underlying uh um what's his mission you
know when you cut prosecutions by 25
while murders rise 51 and shootings rise
100 but he chooses to upgrade a
misdemeanor to a felony for the
president while downgrading felonies uh
to misdemeanors for violent criminals I
mean this dude gets fan mail from Rikers
he's got more blood on his hands in the
Wuhan market so I think that he's
deliberately trying to turn the system
inside out you know he's Reinventing it
as a prosecution arm for the hard left
which it should be pretty chilling to
everybody because no one is safe if he
can do this judge what happened today
with the grand jury do you know yes they
didn't meet
no the D.A didn't call me and tell me uh
I'm sorry
the uh it appears that this is a grand
jury that meets Mondays Wednesdays and
Thursdays it does not meet on Tuesdays
and apparently they told them not to
come in today now the only thing that I
can imagine trying to read the tea
leaves here is that uh according to One
Source the district attorney is having
trouble convincing the grand jury on
potential charges due to weakness of the
case now any D.A has an obligation if
he's going to get a grand jury
indictment to get at least a majority of
the 23 which is a quorum in the grand
jury now if you don't have 20 if you
don't have 12 out of 23 that's a really
a weak case because the case is weak to
begin with but I also think and I don't
obviously know I think Bob Costello who
was a defense attorney uh who's a
defense is witness if you want to call
Donald Trump the defense at this point
went in and testified and made it very
clear to everyone in the grand jury that
repeatedly Michael Cohen said I have
nothing against Donald Trump I have
nothing against Donald Trump I've been
his lawyer I have nothing against him
and he was suicidal and about to kill
himself he was so worried about what was
going to happen to him that Costello
surmised that if he was about to kill
himself if one thing could save him and
that would be uh actually you know
throwing Donald Trump to the Wolves he
would have done it but he kept saying I
have nothing so I think it's a
combination of Costello I think it's a
combination of the grand jury possibly
hearing that you cannot take a federal
crime call it offense and bootstrap into
a misdemeanor to make it a felony and
then you don't have jurisdiction to
prosecute it but I also think if they
are bringing uh Michael Cohen back
they are rehabilitating him now in order
to bring him back so you know they've
got to be real clear because he's got so
many differing opinions and different
statements that he's made on Donald
Trump that that case is falling apart so
I think it's curious that they say maybe
Bragg won't bring it I have a feeling
that maybe the grand jury isn't buying
it and Jessica what do you hear from
Democrats or what do you think about
so many on the left are saying this is
not the case you should bring yeah even
though you had some in the New York
Times saying actually it really makes a
lot of sense that doesn't seem to be
winning the argument no that they're
really the standout ones who are
making that argument publicly it's not
as if people don't think that there may
have been a crime that was committed
it's just a lot bigger of an issue than
like did someone violate the law the
hush money it was at a business expense
not necessarily was it you know did it
turn into kind of a campaign donation
sure but is this where you're going to
go especially at a time where Trump has
what's going on in Georgia he has the
special counsel Jack Smith is still
moving ahead with that is this going to
be the thing that's your entree into
actually going into the legal world with
this
um to Greg's point the the Smart Ones
are saying maybe just take a second on
this one and it is interesting that
Bragg who initially wasn't going to do
this and he said he's going to do it and
I don't know if he had pushback again
from Top prosecutors the ones who stuck
around who just said this is absolutely
not where we should be on this and axios
had a headline up this afternoon that uh
Senators GOP senators are really divided
about the idea of the a House
Republicans want to bring Alvin Bragg in
right they want to uh question him why
are you doing this What's the timing is
this just a partisan stunt and the GOP
Senate is saying let's just get things
done right all this is about
electioneering Nothing Else Matters to
people right then they're political
survival from someone like Alvin Bragg
who everyone hates him now right
um to Senators who need to be reelected
in 2024 and and Congress people and
they're saying let's get some real wins
on the board let's
have an economic plan let's make sure
people have health care the things that
folks really care about
and Jesse it's by President Trump
putting this out there into the world on
Saturday and now everybody's talking
about it it was like heads he wins Tails
he wins because Bragg is losing on both
sides
I'm feeling alive again
we did four years of this and it was one
of the most thrilling moments of most of
our Lives the Russia hoax the Injustice
the leaks
and I'm feeling the adrenaline all of a
sudden like two years with Biden's been
I've been asleep and now I feel like I'm
under a soul I feel like the country's
under assault Trump's under assault the
Trump movement's under assault and I
don't like when people say oh you know I
have to defend this you always have to
defend this good I I want to defend this
and and politics is not just going on
offense politics is defense too and the
left is Relentless and you might be
right there might be more vulnerability
down in Georgia the documents deal is a
wash but this is BS it has nothing to do
with the campaign this is a private
matter with a woman whatever happened to
the left saying oh who cares what
happens in the bedroom let's get the
government out of the bedroom now
they're trying to get in the bedroom
here come on I don't know if Dana read
this bedroom activities for your lawyer
I don't know not through the campaign
well I I don't I don't know if the uh if
you read the New York Times today Russ
but he brought up the Clinton situation
I mean we did years of the Clinton sex
stuff where did that get Bill Clinton he
got approval in the 70s he left well
liked and everybody agreed you know what
everybody lies about sex
this is what this is not even lying
about sex this is not even saying
anything Stormy Daniels denied it after
she signed the NDA and then she came
back with her handout
come on they don't have a love child
like John Edwards there's nothing there
you can't make this into a campaign
Finance deal and then
Bragg wants the mug shot you're right he
just wants the mug shot because you get
a mug shot it's the most viral image of
politics it's like Sonny Liston like
this with Muhammad Ali like that it's
going to go viral all over the world and
they're going to use it in every
campaign for the next two years you're
going to see it in every news every
newspaper and it's going to scare
Republican donors are they going to
throw money at a guy that's been
indicted been booked have been
fingerprinted a lot of these corporate
guys don't want to throw money at a guy
like Trump so that's what this is about
they're trying to criminalize the
president criminalize his movement and
make him look so dangerous that he's
leading this Dark Army of
insurrectionists and that's how the FBI
can get to use those anti-terror tools
against the movement you know what
you're what you're getting at is so true
it is it wasn't us it wasn't fox or the
five that elected Trump in 2016. it was
the very same people pushing this it was
the it was the morning Joe's and the
Discord 4G on CNN that were that that
basically just shoved all the oxygen to
Trump which is exactly what happened
this week and we and for some reason our
muscles were uh were not in use and we
weren't used to it right but it happened
again they they are in the process of
possibly electing Trump Again by giving
him all the oxygen yeah and also what
does it say about the fact that when
Trump had the Department of Justice we
knew that Hillary Clinton had used the
same thing she used a political
operative and a political uh issue
creating the steel dossier that the FEC
was a crime and that was booked the same
way as a legal expense Trump could have
gone after her with the justice
department he didn't do that and yet now
they're trying to make something up to
go after Trump
yeah they're actually trying to lock him
up
everyone and Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now